JACOB TROUBA OPENS ON DEFENSE.
JUST 1:11 SECONDS INTO GAME ONE,
CHRISS KUCHEROV GETS BEAT
, A ONT
THE T.
LAUREN DOWN LOW.
HE CHIPS THE PUCK AT THE
BLUE LINE TO HIMSELFO STEP AWAYM
NICK PAUL, REVERSES DIRECTION.
VASILEVSKIY SAW THATCENTERING P.
PASS
BLOCKING THE SHORT SIDE BY THE
TROUBAAM IN THE LEAGUE.
WRAPAROUND SHOT BY COLTON.
DENIED BTRANO.
HEADS UP AND HE SNAPS IT
PERFECTLY OVER THE BLOCKER. SEC.
THE LIGHTNING, DENIED.
THEN THAT SHOT BYIED THE GAME A.
THEY IS GOING TO SPIN IT,
BACKHAND IT TO THE NET
RANGERS LEAD FOR THE THIRD TIME
TONIGHT TO HAND OFF
OR TURNAROUND AND HAVE HERE IN E
ONE.
OFF THE 30 SECONDS INTO THE THID
PERIOD. THE
INTERMISSION WERE TALKING
CREASE.
SHESTERKIN IS FACE DOWN IN THE T
RANGERS.
SERGACHEV.
REBOUND BY